hey 42 here the word Halloween is
derived from All Hallows Eve All Hallows
Eve is the eve before the Christian
feast of All Hallows on November the 1st
Halloween takes place on the 31st of
October mostly in the Western world more
chocolate and sweets are sold on October
the 28th than any other day of the year
the most popular of which is Snickers
Halloween is the second highest-grossing
commercial holiday after Christmas
Americans spend six billion dollars on
Halloween every year but why do we
celebrate Halloween Halloween started
about two thousand years ago in Ireland
the holiday originated from the Celtic
festival of Samhain Samhain was
celebrated by Celts in Ireland the UK
and northern France
the festival was held to mark the end of
the summer months and harvest time the
darker colder months that followed were
associated with death by the Celts some
Haim began at sunset on October the 31st
they believed this was a time when the
ghosts of the deceased returned to earth
because the boundaries between the world
of the living and the dead were most
blurred so why do we call it Halloween
today the word Halloween comes from the
Christians hallow mass is a free day
Catholic holiday where Saints are
honored and people pray for the recently
deceased at the start of the 11th
century the Pope decided that it would
last from October the 31st until
November the second because that's when
some hain was celebrated and the church
was trying to convert the pagans October
the 31st the start of this Christian
holiday is known as All Hallows Eve
which over the centuries has been
shortened firstly to All Hallows Evan
under ventually in the 18th century to
Halloween the Irish brought their
Halloween like traditions to the u.s. in
1840 however the commercialized
Halloween that we know today didn't
start in the Western world until 1921
and
production of Halloween costumes didn't
start until the 1950s until then
Halloween costumes were homemade and
just plain creepy but why do we dress up
for Halloween in the first place during
the old festival of Samhain spirits were
believed to cross over to the world of
the living for this one night people
began to get scared at the thought of
this
so they wore homemade masks and odd
clothing in an attempt to disguise
themselves from the spirits so any evil
spirit wouldn't harm them
trick-or-treating is a tradition carried
out across most of Europe North America
and some parts of Asia but the ritual of
dressing up and knocking on changes
doors in exchange for sweets differs
greatly in some parts of the world in
France Halloween is seen as an unwanted
American influence and the French rarely
trick-or-treat in fact the French didn't
fully celebrate the holiday until 1996
because of the French Catholic Church's
strong campaign against Halloween
instead of going house-to-house asking
for sweets
French children go from store to store
in Germany it is customary to put away
all their knives because they don't want
the returning spirits to harm themselves
in Sweden Halloween is known as alla
hell guns duck under celebrated for six
continuous days school children are also
given a day off in spanish-speaking
countries such as Mexico Spain and Latin
America Halloween is known as el dia de
las mortis the days of the Dead families
remember their dead relatives by
constructing an altar in their homes
consisting of flowers candy photographs
water and samples of the deceased s--
favorite food and drinks but how did the
tradition of trick-or-treating originate
it all started in England across the
West Midlands and Lancashire in the
early 19th century when children would
go so linked kids would go door to door
singing songs and begging for money food
and drink they would sing songs such as
a soul a soul a soul cake please God
misses a soul cake
appala pair a plumber a cherry any good
thing to make us all marry one for Peter
two for Paul free for him who made us
all the most common treat given out were
soul cakes they were small round cakes
with a cross on top later in 19th
century Britain Solon gave rise to
guising where children would dress up
and beg for fruit and money but instead
of singing songs to earn these gifts
children would put on full-blown
performances such as playing instruments
and reciting poems this tradition
eventually gave way to modern-day
trick-or-treating when the Scottish and
Irish bought it to North America in 1911
but as trick-or-treating really safe
what about all those poisoned candy
scares and worried mummies well you can
relax truth is you're more likely to be
ravaged by zombies than receive tampered
treats there have only ever been two
documented cases of people dying as a
result of eating Halloween goodies the
first was in 1970 when a boy ate a large
amount of heroin that his uncle had
hidden the boy's family sprinkled heroin
on his Halloween sweets and blamed the
sweets instead the second was when a
father poisoned his own son sweets to
get the compensation from a life
insurance policy he had just taken out
on him so what's the lesson here
you should probably be more scared of
your parents than strangers and finally
why do we carve pumpkins in 19th century
Great Britain jack-o'-lanterns were a
form of pranks tourism young boys used
to hollow out and carve faces in turnips
to frighten people on the streets wait a
minute
turnips that's right before pumpkins
jack-o'-lanterns were created from
turnips and the word jack-o'-lantern
well it comes from 17th century Britain
when it literally meant man with a
lantern thanks for the view subscribe
for more 42